pool today
[Music]
[Music]
my nose is so stuffed it's just got to
be copic well your test came back
negative for covid but your your nasal
cavities are clogged with parmesan
cheese i swear i thought it was cocaine
good for you uh let's try clear hunter
x clear
yes it's made by clear ink which is
recognized as the leading manufacturer
of xylitol based products in north
america and this nasal spray is all
natural
all natural what does that mean
uh well that it's drug-free drug-free
that sucks
parmesan is also drug-free just try the
spray
wow
i can breathe right breathing is
important for a person most that person
has dirt on you right
wow
uh let's just be glad that it worked all
right sure did
thanks for showing me the clear way doc
it's my pleasure can you do one more
favor for me
sure
hold on to this laptop for me
uh no
no deal all right how about a
quick prescription of 200 percent get
out of my office
all right i got some good at home
i i told you to quit smoking gouda
this is guy fieri and he's rolling out
[Music]
are you a trucker you are not welcome at
bucky's
no trucks
[Music]
kiss my eyes
[Music]
sorry
one two three there you go thank you
thank you so much thank you thank you
for coming out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
channel
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
ah
that's called a hold on to your butt sip
mm-hmm uh because today is uh oh it's
like i'm gonna get rid of paper i'm
definitely gonna be doing some note
taking today um look
i know this isn't the first place that
you're tuning into today that's
discussing uh gun violence and the
tragedy
that had taken place yesterday okay
that's not lost on me and i know that if
i say
that i'm praying for the families and my
heart absolutely breaks and i think i
speak on behalf of everyone in the
studio that that's the case
that
a good portion of you are going to
comment that oh that's not enough we
need to do something and of course the
atheists will come and spaghetti monster
because they never miss an opportunity
so look let me lead with that and let me
lead with something here
i assume that everyone who's talking
about this
outside of the politicians
and even then probably a good portion of
them
cares
and wants
what's better for this country wants
to limit
violence i don't want to get to just gun
violence i don't want to get to just
mass shootings because that's a very
small subset of violence
and a certainly very small subset of
violence uh as it relates to human
nature throughout history i think that
most people want to cut down on violence
i think that most of you whether you're
left or right want to
cut down on our our kids
being killed okay so let's start from
that
that being said
let me ask you this here's my question
of the day because you see people like
steve kerr out there saying do something
right that's like do something
do you think you make your best
decisions when you're angry and
emotional
in the heat of the moment
is this the right time to start removing
people's fundamental rights or or
changing the very fabric of our
constitution do you think that's when
you have the best judgment i also want
to today look let me lead with two
things
we're going to get to the top five myths
the claims that are being made right now
in the wake of the tragedy that had just
taken place in texas and
has taken the life of at the time of
this
filming 19 uh if i'm not mistaken it's
19 people now or is it 19 children and
then plus two teachers it's 19 plus two
19 plus two yes dear god i hope that
does not include the shooter in there no
it does not they used to do that yeah
they did so uh let me preface it with
this um guns firearms
save far more lives and by that i mean
many many millions more lives each year
in the united states than they take
okay
that's a fact
and ninth depending on the stat you use
94 to 97 will take the low stat 94 of
mass shootings occur in gun-free zones
marley was dead to begin with
let's set the stage with that and then
we'll get into the tired recycled claims
that are being brought out right now
specifically as it relates to this
shooting and there are a handful that
come from former vice president joe
biden and of course are being echoed on
twitter but
let's start with that do something okay
three million defensive uses of firearms
a year versus in the teens of thousands
as far as homicides depending on the
year far more lives are saved by
firearms in this country than are taken
that's an irrefutable fact how if it
saves one life it saves millions of
lives
94 of mass shootings occur in gun-free
zones
if it saves one life okay 94
we need to if we're going to talk about
doing something we need to start with
the highest percentage plays
let's just all assume that we don't know
the cu we don't have causation here but
we have to look at the strongest
correlations
gun-free zones fatherless households
and we can look at these
then we go way way way down the list oh
wait that there's a correlation that
it's always an ar-15 it's not even close
it's not even close so just afford
everyone here the same
the same assumption that we are
affording you right now that you care
and that we care
and that being said
if we make uh if today's show is is is
funny
then we're really really good at our
jobs
i don't know
that remains to be seen yeah i'm mad and
i was mad yesterday think about it i was
just mad at europe
i was mad at europe in general people
were like what are you mad about today
remember i was like europe you're like
what why
why not do i need a reason and today i'm
just i'm i'm i'm angry that i'm more sad
honestly but i get angry and frustrated
with the people who think that they have
the corner on being angry and frustrated
it's like being in a marriage with amber
heard where only one person can have an
emotion
no ev everyone can feel something right
now that's okay that's that's natural
yeah or two people cannot have an
emotion that's true that's called amber
heard marriage yes well i think johnny
jeff started with emotion and then he
was dead inside right she just started
she killed him because i like johnny
jack
well i don't know i mean you know look
once you poop in a bed
it's pretty hard to feel it's unless
you're drunk i've always said that's
fine yes
but even though it's not if you're a
woman because women do not poop so
my question is uh what do you think we
can do and should we hold a bit before
we make some decisions
that's a genuine question because
everyone right now is yelling do
something do something do something
great i get it you're angry then
let's try and examine it a little bit
more let's go a little further down the
trail then i feel something got it we
can't only be a nation of feelings
that's how you end up with six-year-olds
cutting off their penis and then
declaring a mental health crisis as it
relates to
firearms in this country well you know
what hold on a second maybe putting
someone on puberty blockers and cutting
off their penis when they're six might
actually not be most beneficial to
people's mental health we'll get to that
too hey gerald a is here how are you sir
i'm okay i'm okay it's heavy but uh we
look you can either laugh or you can cry
and i choose to laugh a little bit and
get some of the stuff out but uh i think
we're gonna have some
fiery conversations when we get there if
you if you cry you're fired i won't cry
on air i just mean in general when you
have a lot of emotion you can laugh or
you can cry i mean there's other things
you can do but i choose those poop in a
bed and we also have uh you know him you
love him the quickest man on his feet
when i said people like oh you mean in
the studio no i mean ever and uh he is
on tour with me loudwithcredit.com
tour and he's doing his own show here
may 29th an important show gaylord
michigan it's fuel fest all the proceeds
are going to those affected by the
tornado that's correct yes and yeah
friday and cetera we'll be in emily
minnesota um doing big l's and then
we're gonna do this on sunday help raise
some money for the people affected by
the tornado and i did cry a little but i
sat on a pencil ah there you go well
that's okay though if dave doesn't like
it he can sit on a pencil out sit on a
pencil attack yeah that seems a little
bit uh it seems like it's not really
severe enough when they're talking about
satan if the devil doesn't like it he
can sit on attack hold on a second
you're talking about torture rape
enslavement all the evil of humanity you
go uh you go uh sit on attack you big
jerk you know how that doesn't feel good
yeah yeah
oh oh no
meanwhile he's making another guy sit on
a throne of butcher knives you're like
you said on attack oh okay she having a
pineapple in someone yeah
jeez
also voluntarily yes
yes and you know what we have evil at
play right now that's what look i think
that's what we need to acknowledge there
is evil in this world it will always be
amongst you and you know what i think
that our public schools are a breeding
ground for evil
i'll say that
i really do
i really do when you look at the you
can't just silo everything when you look
at the conversations when you look at
trying to uninvolve and detach the
parents from these children's lives when
you're looking at transitioning children
when you're looking at uh brow-beating
young white boys for something they've
never done look i think that it's a
breeding ground for evil
okay
i think it's long before you get to the
point of uh you know a bunch of policies
that won't work on an inanimate object
let's let's understand human nature and
that's if you're a conservative or a
liberal dennis prager talks about that
do you believe that human beings are all
inherently good or all inherently evil
let's remove the term evil because some
of you agnostics are uncomfortable with
it okay selfish
all that's required for someone to be a
sociopath or a narcissist
is just to only think of themselves as
to be selfish we often think that they
have to go out and you know they're
they're they're pulling wings off
dragonflies no
this have to be selfish
that's how it starts
well i believe it was the 50s when there
was a lot more god-fearing than there is
now that they uh asked a group of people
if they would save them hurt another
person to save themselves
and it was like 65 percent of them said
yes
so think about what that number's
probably raised to today it's like a
hundred yeah it's gotta be what 99
points would you hurt certainly in this
studio yes they they answer too quickly
no no no it's just savior i don't care i
would hurt the other person you know
this poll is public sir i don't care we
have video of you can you tell my
neighbor that i said this maybe he'll
start trimming his hedges his name's
john you keep stealing my packaging keep
waxing your boat but not cutting your
lawn john yeah and stop scrolling with
my mail it's a federal offense
all right
so before we get to that little bit of
levity here and we're going to try and
keep levity but we're going to do i know
a lot of you said that you liked the
claim fact format which we're going to
do today because it's sorely needed yes
and all references are available at
credit.com so um
child abuse i don't know if you know
this is uh it's very hot right now
yeah i said levity i know meant both
mental and physical especially among you
know the trans lobby here's a trans dad
yeah i don't want to i should probably
warn you if you have kids it's not like
there's anything really vulgar but
they're not going to want to see this
it's a trans dad who's now crowd funding
to uh help in perpetrating child abuse
here we go i'm raising money to help
fund my son's transition related costs
um basically we already have a diagnosis
of gender dysphoria for him
his blood work done and we need to start
him on puberty blockers as soon as
possible yes it's an emergency that boy
has testosterone in his body
um
i have already exhausted
most of your heart i need help good i
want to raise money to help cover his
trade costs as um nose piercings it's
very difficult to come out with that
sort of money
on short notice
good i know that i'm asking a lot
but i would do anything to make sure
that
he is able to continue his transition
seamlessly
it's very hard to come up with that
amount of money first off there's a
problem why can't you come up with money
on short notice why short notice for a
child's transition see what they do they
just they need access to necessary
medical care a
a fake vagina is necessary i don't know
this is this is the problem when
everything is a human right except for
actual human rights like the right to
self-defense uh i need the money on i
need i need it now this isn't a jg
wentworth commercial
well how about the fact that it's gender
dysphoria what you're trying to say
isn't a thing yeah that was the whole
narrative before now you're saying it is
a thing okay so you can treat this if
you think that it's a problem
right your choice is to treat it with
puberty blockers and cutting off his
penis yes well don't forget getting
breasts he wants breasts oh i'm sorry
right yeah he i i thought it was silly
for a moment yes
for a moment i was worried yes no that
means look at that guy that is the
disease that's a man is it well that's
supposed to be i don't know i'm honestly
saying i really don't know yeah i don't
want to get banned right off the bat
money to that i think it's a trans do we
know what oh okay the go fund is it go
fund me that he was using well he wanted
to be in the crowd funding yeah i would
love to see how much they've raised was
it gofundme that removed the canadian
truckers but that abomination totally
fine
should we plug grumble
oh yeah by the way if yeah it's a good
call if we could ever get removed here
on youtube uh and if we don't by the way
we have no show on memorial day just you
know on monday of course it's federal
holiday and uh we honor those the troops
people who people who've actually been
through trauma
yes that's real
you know not
my son needs puberty blockers now and
breasts and the very brave small
soldiers that were put on puberty
blockers yes well they fought the
gorgonauts
that was a very mediocre film but i
still like it i like it it's like
neverland right but you know it's my
genitals yes exactly it's the freak show
in the cupboard
now the ghost of penis is passed rumble
rumble you can go to rumble or louder
crowded or you can go live with
crowd.com club monday through thursday
at 10 a.m eastern 10 a.m eastern monday
through thursday if ever we get removed
from youtube if we don't tell you that
there is no show it means there is a
show you can just tune in live
there no show monday consider yourself
warned i don't want to hear your
complaining
go to the beach of the pool and enjoy
yourselves
yes
leave us alone careful not everyone is
pool privileged just think about that
for a second then we're gonna have a
discussion about mental health in this
country when people say we're i think we
can find common ground okay common
ground we're discussing mental health
hey let me ask you something really
quickly before we move on to this
because
the rest of the show is going to be
debunking these gun myths that are going
so it's it's it's a pretty thorough show
just to let you know so i want to hit
this off the top the rest of this
trans person in the united states more
at risk being the victim of a mass
shooting or suicide one's a 42 attempted
rate both pre and
and the other is you know single-digit
percentage of one percentage point the
mental health crisis okay
american slaves
jews in the holocaust didn't have that
kind of an attempted suicide rate you
want us to believe that it's because
they can't take a dump in their
preferred bathroom of choice at a
walmart
i don't buy it
just me well men's man's search for
meaning is a great book and it's about a
guy i mean it's a true story of somebody
who lived through the hollywood tr
through the hollywood kind of the same
holocaust yeah and had uh what a
freudian slip
uh hollywood is the 911 of entertainment
but and you know kept a certain positive
attitude and that's a very i can't even
imagine how difficult that is but with
this particular kid and you're talking
about mental health okay
let's look at just to say real quick the
shooter and not just have not saying
that you have to have any empathy or
whatever but you're looking at a kid
with abandonment issues who lived with
his grandma killed his grandma you have
all these things going on
she's still alive okay i'm sorry shot
her is she still alive i think the last
i heard she was still good that's a
tough old bird okay i didn't mean to uh
sorry uh youtube for any misinformation
you pieces of [ __ ]
so
we've acknowledged this
so you have
you have this kid and then you have
two and a half years
of hiding faces locking people inside
making them feel worthless collapsing
the world collapsing the economy making
it difficult not giving anybody the
proper access to the treatment they need
worrying more about doing surgery that
is completely unnecessary
on people that do need help and you
wonder why this kind of thing happens
and we're gonna go ahead and blame
guns right it's insane to me that we're
getting to this point and i speak
honestly from my heart as somebody who
deals with mental illness right it is
myself too i'm talking absolutely yeah
exactly it's tragic yeah and you know
what else think about
people use the term canceling what is
canceling really well when you look at
people like abraham lincoln when you
look at people like winston churchill
when you even look at people like
richard your face or dave chappelle it's
about taking the one aspect that you
don't like of somebody the worst aspect
and defining them that way winston
churchill flawed sure drank a lot
cheated on his wife also the man who
stood between hitler and the rest of the
free world
shouldn't he be recognized a little bit
more for that and you don't think that
and then you demand that we we not be
judgmental
what kind of mental health issues do you
think that's going to create for young
men yeah you're trapping them they feel
trapped they can do no right they have
no out
they tell they're not needed right
well they're told that they're actually
a burden on society a lot of them plus
if you're wearing the mask how are you
going to show everyone your uh your your
your hot topic uh mascara and
lipstick and it looks good on you yeah
i mean i when i'm not here you would not
recognize me i just look like i'm the
lead singer from under oath back in
2004. so
let's look at some of the reactions here
to the shooting
and uh
um this happened in texas i uh how do
you pronounce the city correctly because
of aldi what is it uvalde is it uvalde
i've heard also people say evolved
i don't think it's evolved i don't think
it's evolved either i thought it was i
don't know i just wanted you to be on
the hook
i'm not sure is it near closer to
houston no it's it's uh near san antonio
right yeah closer to the border yeah
yeah much of the world while we talk
about guns that's a good point yeah
closer to the border we talk about guns
and uh wouldn't have a problem with that
with open borders
no gun running no nary a gun runner to
be found no no no no what was that
program where they uh ran guns yeah yeah
i remember the uh i can't i can't
remember the name of the program
best and furious there we go i was
thinking sons of anarchy yeah well
that's a show actually there are a lot
of them
yeah fast and furious seems spot on to
how it really works yeah fast and
furious is also something yeah because
you can fit a lot of illegal unmarked
rifles in the back of a honda civic with
nitro you can they're just street racing
listen yeah you can grappling hook a
truck yeah that's how they do it yeah
this is brazil well you can if you're
ludicrous yes that's true
first name ludicrous last name ludacris
yeah not that guy just the actual term
right ludicrous
hey you know what i want to go to chris
murphy before we go to steve kerr the
golden state warriors so how do you know
that this is that there's political
grandstanding going on like i said i
believe that you care we care not
necessarily all the politicians they see
this as an opportunity unfortunately and
then it'll bring us to steve kerr
because he doesn't understand how a
constitutional republic works but here
is uh connecticut senator chris murphy
saying something and very clearly not
meaning it how do i know because he says
he's going to literally do something and
then doesn't do it
but i'm here on this floor
to beg to literally get down on my hands
and knees and beg my colleagues
turns out the only was on his knees in
the green room yes
he saw him kind of like like he was
gonna he was gonna go and he's like i
don't want people to have that picture
of me that's gonna be photoshop city so
let me just stay standing yeah outside
you have to bag usually you don't even
have to ask yeah
usually you just have to say yes
i am literally on my hands and knees to
beg and you want to say we can find some
kind of common ground this is what they
always okay common ground all right like
what background checks it's already a
thing yeah hey what on a second we find
common ground you see necessary medical
care is chopping off the penises of boys
where's the common ground at that point
we are so far beyond common ground
we need to course correct when people
say oh we've divided more no no
democrats have gone left and republicans
have gone left
and then maybe some less left
but we need to course correct and
understand in our country what the
constitution means and if it means
anything at all because you do have one
party in this country that wishes we
were like all of the other countries and
we'll get to that in a second that don't
have the constitution we have it is a
different country by design for a reason
so he says that that's how you know
what's grandstanding is i'm gonna get on
my hands and knees
do it go ahead i wasn't actually going
to get on my hands on my knees but you
said you literally were i meant
figuratively but you said literally i
meant literally figuratively you're a
dick
well it's just
it's like you said it's just
grandstanding how long are we going to
be held captive to our politicians right
along until we change actually change
something and do something voluntarily
captive we're we are imprisoning
ourselves right now we're listening to
the stupidest people ever
and they're running our country
yeah it is pretty apparent when you're
watching nfc you're like this is a
really dumb person yeah please tell us
your thoughts on gun control you [ __ ]
yes well googly eyed idiot i wrote a
bell that's not a hard argument to me
no that's how it's mad that's you're
just reading the police description yeah
yeah crazy lady with eyes that are
googly i repeat googly we need a sketch
artist i'm surprised she doesn't come
out of a clock every time she talks yeah
exactly you read the police report
you're like are you describing someone
from sesame street
it's a congresswoman her eyes go both
ways that's not possible is it oh it is
oh yeah they just turn around a picture
like snuffle up i guess no no it's aoc
wow
phrase is my boyfriend's feet yeah oh
weird not really a catchphrase just
something she sort of laments repeatedly
uh and now let's go to the golden state
warrior coach steve kerr everyone's
talking about this it's gone viral and
because it's impassioned
great but passion in the absence of
information or education is of no value
so let's watch when are we gonna do
something
i'm tired i'm i'm so tired of getting up
here and
offering condolences to
to the
devastated families that are out there
i'm so tired of the excuse i'm sorry i'm
tired of the moments of silence
enough
there's 50 senators
right now who refuse to vote on h.r 8
which is a background check rule that
the house passed a couple years ago it's
been sitting there for two years
background check's already a thing and
there's a reason they won't vote on it
to hold on to power
i ask you mitch mcconnell i ask all of
you senators who refuse to do anything
about the violence in school shootings
and supermarket shootings i ask you
are you going to put your own
desire for power ahead of the lives
of our children and our elderly and our
church-goers
because that's what it looks like your
own desire for power okay let's examine
that a little bit here
this is also the same person where you
have a lot of people made this argument
90 of americans support background
checks well of course so do i they
already exist
you say giving up your own power yeah i
i i want to i want to uh get more of a
grip on i want more power so you should
all own guns said no dictator ever just
to be clear and hey if you're talking
about power it's a constitutional
problem it's a representative republic
the only way they would maintain power
is
people voting for them the easiest way
to get a grip on power is be like a joe
biden who's never held the same view
twice on an issue
so how is someone like a ted cruz based
on your premise how is someone like a
rand paul
making a decision to protect the
constitution just to try and maintain
their grasp on power when you say that
it's an incredibly unpopular viewpoint
and they have to be elected
none of it adds up yeah well and steve
kerr is universally seen as a good guy
so many people out there right now who
see steve kerr and go oh it's a good guy
making he's uninformed guys this is the
problem you get angry you get frustrated
and of course everybody wants this to
stop but you don't have the information
all you have is the left once again
virtue signaling and saying common sense
gun reform background checks every
single how many times do we have to
debunk this how many videos do you have
to make where you going and prove to
people that you can't get a gun at a gun
show without well do you know why i
contract from a dealer i have to do it
again because sometimes if you search
top top ar 15 myths even though we have
videos that have many many i think over
10 million plays 50 million players it
won't show up you'll see something from
pbs talking about how dangerous ar-15s
are so we have to continually go through
these points because the left is allowed
to recycle their points and everything
they say unchallenged unchallenged the
top of the search engine
and we have to repeat it because you can
search for something we put a lot of
work into all ref all references
available on lottery credit we make the
references available in the description
and you won't find it
that's fine what team does he coach the
golden state warriors oh i see so um do
you mean the the league um that stood
behind a group that burned down cities
and illegally bought guns
well that's ancillary to the point oh i
see yeah yeah because that could have
started with them like maybe he could
have not supported violence i do see
your point i do see your point okay i
don't know if it's entirely valid but i
see your point okay i'm also curious he
referenced the shooting you mean
entirely valid right yeah
yeah i misspoke okay the state with some
of the most strict gun laws in the
country new york right that was that's
the state that he referenced as well and
also he referenced a a church asian chur
church goers in california a state with
very strict gun laws yeah these these
gun laws that you think we should all
live under that have obviously not done
anything to help the
again far more lives are saved
by firearms in the united states than
are taken
94 percent of mass shootings occur in
gun free zones and
decreasing gun ownership increasing
strict gun laws in states does not lead
to decreased crime these are facts
these are facts that you need to start
with and then we can get into some
specific claims let me give you for
those who don't know i mean i'm sure
you've seen this ad nauseam but we know
at this point um shooter 18 year old
hispanic male
22 is it 22 victims right now 22 news 21
when i wrote it here this morning so 22
victims uh he had a rifle and a handgun
he was wearing some kind of not a not a
kevlar vest but some kind of body armor
plate carrier opened fire of course at
rob elementary school you validate texas
and it is important note that he was
stopped by one single border patrol
agent who had been working nearby this
is from abc news when shooting began uh
he meaning the border patrol agent
rushed into school without waiting for
backup and shot and killed the gunman
hey here's another thing
hero
i think wounded in the process and was
able to get out of the building here's
another question how has every single
mass shooting that was stopped meaning
one that didn't just continue until the
perpetrator got away or tired
how is every single one of them what's
what's a 100 percent maybe let's call it
99 constant
stopped by what what guy with a gun so
when you say a good guy with a gun that
uh old west cowboy meth well a second
what about well are the police okay
what did the police show up with
sticky hands praying mantis style no the
guy showed up with a gun now let me just
let me just back that up a little bit
because there are solutions being
offered on both sides and of course the
side the left claiming that they want to
find common ground is dismissing those
in the right that's just crazy that's
asinine okay so you know that all of
these mass shootings right all these
people all these criminals these
homicidal maniacs when they commit these
crimes the only way to stop them is by
someone who has equal or greater force
someone else with a gun you call on them
the police
but you've heard an ounce of prevention
is worth a thousand pounds of defense or
cure depending on which you know in
sports we'll say now it's prevention's
worth 10 000 tons of defense in
wrestling look
you're saying after the fact call the
guy with a gun when we say hey instead
of after the fact how about having
someone with a gun there beforehand
can you believe that republicans are
suggesting that there should be armed
police or the teachers should be allowed
to
you're calling a guy with a gun after
the fact that's your only solution
all i'm saying is maybe we should
protect our children or afford them the
same protection as congress gets yep
that's it or a famous person who wants
to go out in public and gets recognized
that's all i'm asking for and most of
those people by the way like lebron
james will come out and say oh we have
to do something lebron are you offering
your security team to go to the nearest
elementary school and make sure kids are
safe no he's too busy
he's reading the malcolm x biography or
are you calling out a police officer
calling out a police officer for saving
somebody's life yeah in ohio if i
remember correctly and by the way i just
want to clarify 19 children dead two
teachers dead if you throw in the
grandmother being shot as a victim as
well that's the 22 number right so the
grandmother did i don't know that she's
dead i'm just saying she sucks so she's
part of that list all right so right now
they're saying be clear
purchase legally purchased two rifles we
don't know at this point if they can
confirm that he had that other rifle we
know that he had a rifle and a handgun
at the scene at this moment right now if
you're watching this a day or two later
we're not wrong this is the information
we have now we're very very careful to
not go beyond the information that we
have unlike cnn but he also had a
history okay they'll use it to divide us
even further that's what it'll be about
let's turn it into race let's turn it
into sex let's turn it into everything
else except for what the actual thing is
anybody who has a child going to school
they even had you know dad from parkland
but any any ch anybody with a child
going to school yeah you're going to
tell me that you wouldn't feel safer
knowing that there was a guard even un
you know just you know he doesn't have
to wear a uniform just somebody that you
know is there you're gonna tell me that
wouldn't at least detour the kid what
are you supposed to do when a gunman
comes into a school have you ever been
so mad you're seeing red and nobody can
reason with you now imagine if your
psyche is completely broken right what's
the other option you're gonna go this is
not when you're gonna talk to them right
no this is now time for the mental
health evaluation yeah i'm supposed to
feel better as a father because they
passed universal background checks and
hr 8 made it through congress right
that's what's supposed to make me sleep
better even though it's already a thing
but we had a cops at our school in
canada yeah one of them i remember it
turned out he was selling drugs to the
kids yeah i bought drugs it was a
captive audience i remember exactly who
it was we had parking lot attendants
yeah three of them yeah why bought drugs
off of one he was like 60. he had a lot
of racial slurs online yeah tattooed on
them but uh
those are called sailor tips yeah he
must have wore sleeves to the interview
i'll tell you that yeah but uh you had
three people and i think back then ago
you were guarding the parking lot from
kids getting out yeah yeah nobody was
guarding the kids i know no we had
people who would circulate in the school
at lunch hours so that we would have
officers and i never felt uncomfortable
keep in mind steve kerr protested right
having armed officers in oakland yeah he
did hmm what
defund the police wasn't that a movement
ah something like that i mean i just i
think i remember that by the way this
guy was in the building for half an hour
30 minutes until he was taken out
30 minutes and by the way on cnn right
now look at that car
that's not an abandoned car that is i
wrecked my car and jumped it into the
ditch okay the tires are splayed out
right everything this this was not
something that could not have been
prevented from the very beginning right
it's not like one of those things where
they said i don't know he was an a
student he was really quiet it's like no
no no no this is a guy who wore uh a guy
who wore eyeliner who said kids be
scared on his social media and who
crashed his car and loitered around for
30 minutes probably yelling insane like
oh we wish we could have known well no
they said he he was i mean he was in the
building for half an hour you know
during this shooting process but they're
like oh you been in his car i'm like i
thought he parked on the grass yeah no
he didn't he like tried to run his truck
yeah when i first again when i first
read it i thought maybe he you know he
slipped in the expectant mother spot i
didn't know that no he was rolled over
in a ditch you're telling me somebody in
the administrator's office which is
typically if you've never been to an
elementary school i just want to let you
know how this works you walk into a set
of doors there's another set of doors
that goes into the school to the right
is a door to the administrator's office
around that side goes a door into the
rest of them they're listening to the
doors go through to get in there you
have to go to administration check in
tell them who you are show an id then
you get into the school you're telling
me somebody can't be armed in that
administrator's office there's not just
one person there there's secretaries
there there's probably 10 or 15 people
one of them can't be concealed carry at
the point of entry no no you don't
understand we need more useless
employees i.e the real heroes and not
people who would actually stop a
shooting
sorry let me uh and then we'll go into
the debunking of five claims that are
being made right now that you are most
likely to hear if you're on twitter if
you're on facebook or if you're
listening to or watching any legacy
media let me again set the stage
far more lives are saved by firearms in
this country 1.67 million uses of
firearms and defensive situations last
year contrast that with the cdc data in
2020 19 000 gun homicides okay not even
close
many years at three million defensive
uses of firearms yeah
uh 94 percent of mass shootings take
place in gun-free zones okay
reference available with credit.com
texas law in general uh doesn't allow
firearms on school grounds certainly not
elementary schools unless you're close
to them right i think it's like within
300 feet and there's another rule within
a thousand feet yeah so we have laws in
place he broke all of them guys so here
let's go through the claims that are
being to be bigger yes they do need to
be bigger scientists
i think the solution is we need less
secretaries yeah what do they do you can
be replaced by alexa apparently they're
sure to their jobs they can't hit a 911
button right i know yeah well they
forget the number yep now
here is uh and this comes straight from
the former vice president horse's mouth
gave a speech yesterday and he
immediately pivoted to gun control which
has eluded him his career so the first
claim that they're making
is
that this shooting is the fault of the
gun lobby
so many crushed spirits
so tonight
i asked the nation to pray for them
oh each [ __ ] give the parents and
siblings the strength
in the darkness they feel right now part
of my language
as a nation we have to ask when in god's
name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby
in god's name
we do we all know in our gut needs to be
done
no
no you know in your gut the most
important thing for a child is to affirm
the gender they want to be he gave that
speech so let's be really clear here
that's the claim here's the truth okay
first off no one from the gun lobby
killed anyone yesterday okay let's be
clear let's also hold the person who
pulled the trigger accountable uh and
the gun lobby is far less influential
than people want to make them out to be
less influential than unions for example
less influential than telecom companies
but certainly some companies i think are
of note in 2021 gun law uh gun rights
lobbyist spent a total of 15.8 million
dollars okay compare that to
pharmaceuticals
356 million electronics 179 million
insurance 153 million it's not even
close 15.8 million to
356
million dollars from pharmaceutical
companies hey but by the way
have pharmaceutical companies killed any
kids
hmm i don't know the reports are
redacted and they need 50 years to let
us know yeah yeah it's very nice 80 000
pages one day we'll know but we won't
know we'll be dead by the time it comes
out probably because kids took all the
pharmaceuticals yeah but by the way does
the nra do anything other than promote
responsible gun ownership
they spend money on boats and planes huh
i'm not a big fan of the internet i'm
not no i'm not not no but i know what
i'm just saying like if you're going to
hold their feet to the fire and look at
okay like flip okay responsible gun
ownership yeah you know the people that
have concealed carry we even went over
this are less likely to commit a crime
than a police officer yep right it's not
even close gone through the statistics
so you can hate the nra fine maybe you
don't like the organization i get it
this kid wasn't an nra member following
the playbook right okay he didn't read
the nra go shoot up a school he wasn't a
regular at the charlton heston fan club
so again it's just lazy we're just
starting this off because this is how
lazy the left is it's whip you up
emotionally and then here's a target the
gun lobby okay and do me a favor don't
invoke god's name the week after coming
out on abortion and saying yes this
should be the law of the land for
everybody i know we're not tying these
two issues together but please don't
tell me what god wants in this situation
when you have no clue obviously and
should be denied communion if you're
catholic nancy pelosi that was the right
decision sorry yes it was not according
to pop whoopee well pope whoopee you're
right that's fair the point to communion
is i'm hungry child
more page flipping i used to be a nun
that was a movie
i don't remember i get confused with
diabetes
i walk with a cane i got the sugar brain
they told me i had to lose weight i
still gonna be diabetic i said how much
a foot weight my purple toes are
bleeding so
let's get to another claim that they
make here's the second claim that is
really common right now and you're
hearing this everywhere okay
uh and you're hearing it from donald uh
from uh from former vice president biden
donald trump was far more accurate when
these events happened by the way what
happened to trump's america every time
there was a shooting is this buying
america
i just want to make sure that i
understand because we have far more
crime overall which is what i'm more
concerned with violent crime not just
the tool and the whole war thing yeah
the whole war thing the whole 40 billion
ukraine okay so the claim is
we're the only country and you hear this
a lot
we're the only country where this kind
of thing happened i just got off
a trip from asia meeting with
asian leaders
thank you for joining i learned of this
while i was on the aircraft
oh good and what struck me surprised you
didn't say oriental on that
17-hour flight what struck me
was these kinds of mass shootings rarely
happen anywhere else in the world wrong
why
they have mental health problems
they have domestic disputes in other
countries
they have people who are lost
but these kinds of masculinities never
happen with the kind of frequency that
happened in america why okay so first
off there's a slight of hand that's
taking place there and i want to sort of
go through a couple of points but here's
the truth okay
we are not the country first off
with the most violent crime or the most
amount of murders or homicides it's not
even close when you look at it per
capita so if you look from 2018 you have
el salvador you have jamaica uh jamaica
you have uh honduras where does america
land on the list we're like
we're like 83rd
okay less than five homicides per 100
000 compare that to number one el
salvador 52.
so he was only 83 off yes well this is
this is important i'm going through the
violent crime rate and the homicide rate
now the left wants it both ways where
they say oh you can't compare us to el
salvador or honduras why not well
because those countries are shitholes
do you mean to say they're third world
so it's not fair to compare it
well good thing is we have another
statistic here we're not even the
country with the most uh mass shootings
per capita even among the
first world countries which i guess is
the term that we would have to use now
if you look at the death rates per
million from 2009 to 2015 you have
norway you have serbia you have
macedonia the united states is 11th but
here's the thing let's even assume that
there is an outlier trend of mass
shootings in the united states okay i
let's it's not reference available
ladder with credit.com
i'm still more concerned with the
violent crap uh violent crime rate and
the homicide rate and it's not even
close
so this is why they want to focus on the
tool and this is why you get a lot of
people who they'll accuse you of being
conspiratorial
because you see rising violent crime
right now why is there rising violent
crime like dave just pointed out earlier
because they encouraged the writing yet
kamala hara saying don't stop the
rioting and so what does that
necessitate well there's an increase in
firearm purchases so there's a rise in
crime through liberal rhetoric through
leftist policy
and they say look at the rise in crime
we need to what remove more of your
rights
and i legally purchased a firearm after
that happened
i was never big into them in my entire
life i was never really comfortable with
them that's just my own personal opinion
once that started happening i learned
how to shoot i learned how to shoot from
a marine
and
it's something that i feel like you have
to have now and it's a result
of their politics
yeah well and i remember after
yeah
i'm trying to think of that the city
name for some reason saluting me but the
hands up don't shoot right ferguson
ferguson right so all of those leaders
that came out and said black people the
cops are out to kill you out to kill you
i have to kill you
a police officer that went to my church
was among those that was shot and killed
at a protest
right after that i mean dallas in dallas
it was mostly peaceful though right it
was mostly peaceful other than the guy
shooting police officers and killing
them and i i just don't i don't
understand where he probably got the
idea that police officers were after
them yeah every single time they go out
and do stuff like this and they're like
well it's not our fault police are
actually out to kill black people when
that's not absolutely what's the
solution you should be able to uh sue
smith and wesson yeah that's actually a
solution from the left just to be clear
to sue not only gun manufacturers but
mom and pop gun shop owners okay so
their claim is this is the only country
where that happens that's not true
right so we've gone through okay first
claim is the fault of the gun lobby all
right now you know the truth this is the
only place where that happens that's not
true here's another claim right now the
third claim that you're going to hear a
lot you're going to see it on twitter
you're going to see it everywhere and
you heard the president reiterate this
the former vice president i apologize
admonishment admonish admonish me please
i need to respect the office i need to
respect the office former vice president
so the claim is that their common sense
gun control
would have
somehow prevented or had any effect on
this shooting i am sick and tired of it
we have to act
and don't tell me
we can't have an impact on this carnage
i spent my career as a senator and a
vice president your life working to pass
common sense gun laws
we can it won't prevent every tragedy
but we know they work
and have positive impact no
no that's wrong now something you see a
lot on twitter everywhere that they tie
to this is universal background checks
you just heard that from steve kerr we
need background checks background checks
are already a thing yeah just to be
clear i had a background check for
several days yeah if you want to if you
want to debunk the myth of the idea that
there are no background checks look
just have your just go buy a firearm
with any family member or friend and
then you can just say oh you know i
don't want to buy it just have them get
to the paperwork phase right away they
go oh i'm being lied to that's why you
increase firearm ownership in this
country and guess what it becomes really
really hard for politicians to lie they
said oh no background checks and people
everyone at home was going [ __ ] i
just did a background check what are you
talking about yeah it's it's that much
of a disconnect from reality texas
already requires background checks uh
customers let me read it exactly
customers at licensed dealers sorry yeah
that's the truth i should have said
licensed gun dealers in the state of
texas are required to pass an fbi
background check and by the way the
shooter
purchased his firearm that way put your
background check some shooters don't
a lot of them do pass a background check
anyway just to be clear it already
exists so when someone says we need to
do something what we have a bill that
just demands background checks you go
hold on a second we already have
background checks what else is in that
bill
yeah
that's the follow-up question but you
can only ask it if you have a baseline
of knowledge
they don't want you to have that
no and do me a favor and show me what
shooting would have been stopped by a
background check
i mean maybe there's a handful maybe
there's a couple but you're saying
there's been 200 plus mass shootings
this year so far how many of those are
stopped by your your
end-all be-all solution and that's by
the way that's assuming this is
predicated on the idea that the
criminals who are willing to commit mass
murder would obey the laws of a
background
so even assuming that the numbers still
still don't hold up and by the way it's
this was such a pervasive myth that uh
after we had to change my mind on a
campus i took two girls to a firing
range and then went through the process
to purchase a firearm with them because
these girls were anti-gun and they had
never actually learned anything about
firearms and they were shocked to find
out they had to fill up paperwork and
pass a background check you can we did
this as an entire like 30 minute video
how about we just go through the
background check okay let's go through
okay so let's let's do it as you're
gonna get that yeah um but let's do the
back background check
pretty thorough questionnaire there huh
yeah did that surprise you
yeah i didn't think there was like
that
yeah
and he's putting it through the database
right now so the fbi let us know if
you've lied about any of those questions
they lied about all of them
no i don't know if you can hear i was at
death's door you sound like i had a
sinus infection a bronchial infection
and walking pneumonia and i was like oh
my god i gotta go to a gun range today
you asked them to shoot you and they
wouldn't they wouldn't no
please have mercy
can't you hear me and uh the in their
common sense gun laws they want if you
look at the things they want again the
bill is not about a background check
again texas already has gun-free zones
with schools
didn't protect the victims he didn't go
oh my god there's a sign there i better
stop right look at the money that goes
to other countries we put 40 billion
dollars to ukraine yeah there's 98 700
ish let's try and round it up to 90 you
know let's just call 99 000 public
schools in america we take the 40
billion to ukraine that means each
school that's public in america can have
four hundred and four point four
thousand dollars
to spend on school security that's this
year yeah do you think that could be
four people per school hey by the way
people for school what were those forty
billion dollars spent on protecting
ukrainians and not at home and not only
that guns for the ukrainians crazy it's
weird you you need help please send guns
here's 40 billion
here we say hey schools need help please
send guns
if it saves one life that's our point
well basically ukraine is saying help
bad guys with guns what do you do you
say okay well we'll get you more guns to
fight them but in the united states it
can't possibly be the answer and i think
last night i think this is something
that just crystallized for me
it's not even just that they're wrong
every single time that they come out
with their common sense gun reform one
they don't even list what that is two
they always pivot to kind of background
checks and that's about the only thing
then they make stupid claims about ghost
guns or assault weapons or whatever it
may be but they don't list specifics
we have specifics that will work
every single time the low-hanging fruit
that you talked about i'm tired of your
virtue signaling do not give an inch on
this conservatives this is not the way
to do it legislation will never get
people to stop being evil you're never
going to get all guns out of america so
why don't you just let people protect
themselves why don't you make sure
schools are safe why don't you get rid
of gun free zones and soft targets i
want a shooter if he ever walks into a
church or a school to have his head on a
swivel not knowing when it's going to
get blown off by somebody coming out of
a classroom not walking around
willy-nilly for half an hour yeah keep
in mind this whole shooting should never
happen took place in one classroom one
that's like shooting fish in a barrel
you go all right contain them in the
they saw the signs gun-free zone
i even get to hang out for half an hour
and have lunch because no one can do
anything it's like people they act as
though they're the only ones who are mad
they act as though they're the only ones
who care no you have things that we can
do right now look look let's let's
distill they cared it wouldn't have
happened i know if their ideas worked it
wouldn't have happened right the fact
that he's sitting there saying somebody
has to do something you're the
president yeah good believe right thank
you
but it's like it's you former vice
president you're the sorry admonishment
you're the former vice president yes
respect the office i know it's wrong if
you disagree with a man we all agree you
respect the lesson yes sharp is attacked
yes on satan's ass satan can sit on him
yeah this is this is one of those issues
where um let's distill it okay a woman's
being raped there's a man who's a rapist
okay
the rape is already happening we have to
assume that there there are going to be
rapists as long as humans are alive as
long as animals are alive by the way
peter doesn't like to tell you about
that now
ducks they're raping they like them yeah
with their corkscrew penises
so howard rapists
exist
now we can put everything in place that
we want to to try and prevent but a rape
is go let's assume that there will be a
rape happening okay at some point
what does that woman do she have a sign
call the cops you and i both know that
woman's only chance is having a firearm
so if you create a law that strips her
of the right to have a firearm you are
relegating her to being raped
with no defense it's the same thing if
you decide no one in school should be
allowed to have the only defensive tool
that would be able to stop an attack
okay so what do what do you propose well
they're all these are the laws that
really wouldn't do much and then of
course you call the cops afterwards with
the tool that would be needed to stop
the attack preventatively is just it's
crazy talk
if it saves one life well guess what we
already went through it
saves 1.6 last year 1.6 million
sometimes 3 million
if it saves what about you if it saves
one life if it saves one life the
numbers show that you will kill more
people we're just as mad here's another
claim that is very common that you've
heard before
it's sort of you can predict this which
claims are going to be recycled because
they don't work and then they rehash
another one and uh this is that uh like
you mentioned ghost guns non-existent
terms
uh that assault weapons which means
nothing are to blame when we pass the
assault weapons ban
mass shootings went down nope wrong when
the law expired mass shootings tripled
nope
the idea that an 18 year old kid
can walk into a gun store and buy two
assault weapons it's just wrong rifles
what in god's name do you need a solvent
for except to kill someone hey okay good
look first off show me where the
tripling comes from second uh what's an
assault weapon
uh any weapon if you want to use it for
assault i suppose i would suppose but
for him is that well i don't know if it
has a grip like this it's but it's okay
but it feels like oh
yeah
oh
matt finish oh ah matt finish oh man
that's so dangerous i know you yeah it's
in your rapist defense kit but that has
a matte finish we only allow the the
blued finish yeah meanwhile when he was
a kid he could walk in any store and get
liquor eight guns that he wanted yeah
eight packs of cigarettes and then he
just shot his gun on his front porch
into the air yes go out with your
shotgun and shoot it up any minority he
wanted yeah
well he didn't want any of them in his
town no then i was a tough kid from
scranton yeah no there's me saying the
n-word a whole bunch [ __ ] nobody holds
me accountable
so right there he makes a claim about
the assault weapons ban okay
not true uh gun violence was already on
a downward trajectory before the ban in
1994 and then when it was rescinded uh
in the early 2000s it continued to fall
it was 2004. yeah and it was very steady
actually if you look really closely at
the data barack obama was pushing that
oh hey we used to have this ban on
assault weapons and it was fantastic it
lowered all the gun crime no it actually
went up during that specific period of
time after the ban was in place and it
has settled out since and that's why
they try to hide behind terms like mass
shooting specifically as opposed to
homicide or gun crime because the term
isn't necessarily defined consistently
some places define it as four deaths or
more that used to be what was used right
back when i used to talk about this in
2015 now some of them say three people
injured or more but
then they would be covering all the gang
crime that takes place every single
weekend those would be mass shootings so
it really depends on what's most
convenient what you need to look for
what is a constant is violent crime
homicide and then if you want to look at
gun crime because you believe that you
would stop all the rest of homicides and
violent crime without a gun but if you
want to say not only violent crime not
only homicide not only gun crime but
specifically mass shootings which are
such a small subset of the problem then
just admit that you don't want to solve
the problem you are you are losing the
argument so you're trying to score some
political points by the way let's be
really clear again 94 of shootings in
gun-free zones that's a pretty high
correlation doesn't necessarily equate
to causation they believe that causation
is the assault weapon even though 59
percent
59
of these crimes
are attributed to handguns when you're
taking into account uh uh
homicides with firearms less than three
percent three percent with rifles of any
kind
so 94 gun free zones hey i think that
might be a problem you monster we need
to solve the problem of the three
percent
not even three percent because that's
all rifles i don't know what percentage
of them are ar-15s
yeah and you say that we're the ones who
don't care
and i love how the media is focusing on
the rifles right now and not the handgun
that he had right
illegally right
i don't know if he had the handgun
illegally you can't buy a handgun at his
age i think they changed that
you used to be able to not if i set it
up before the show i'm not 100 sure if
i'm 100 right well because those girls
those girls they wanted to purchase
actually a walther uh and uh they
couldn't because they weren't 21. i
thought they'd reduce the age to 18 but
it could just be the rifles can someone
let us know yeah you're probably right i
was looking at the code just a little
bit before we we came on air just to
make sure because he did buy the rifles
legally because former vice president
joe biden said that he bought the rifles
legally i was like sure but then it's
the handguns that you can't until you're
20. it used to be 21. if it's still 21.
is this that more of the concealed idea
as well
that they lowered it or is there a
specific i i think that has more to do
with the history of hunting you know
where people would hunt pretty young you
know with a handgun no you know well you
can i think yeah but well it depends on
what your husband's or something like
that but yeah well it depends too if
that deer cut me off in traffic right
then i'm going after it with whatever i
yeah anything
if you're two gangsters running after a
russian spy in the woods yeah
by the way uh also they talk about how
assault weapons high capacity magazines
which is the silliest thing because
again it's just arbitrary uh hey what
number is too many for rounds ah
ten
why why
tens the number here
do you have
crime stats that show us that guns with
more than ten ten ten the number's 10.
so uh we can look at states that have
high magazine bands
new york california dc new jersey
colorado mass shootings have still
occurred in those places
i can't remember i don't remember if
that started there so the recent ones
let's look at the recent ones buffalo
new york brooklyn subway terrorists the
church in california dc sniper shooting
burgers in new jersey boulder colorado
so the point is these place these places
are not immune to people using firearms
and again we're looking at the number 94
percent
of
these mass shootings the current
gun-free zones they save far more lives
than they take less than three percent
of homicides with firearms are being
committed with
long rifles let alone long rifles with
high capacity magazines and they're
saying this is a solution of the problem
this is where we can find common ground
it is not
honest i get that you're pissed gerald
is obviously very pissed so is dave so
am i i'm trying to button it up here
because i know that i can fly off the
handle i'm really mad i've got two i've
got two young babies at home believe me
i think about this they will never be in
a public school yeah
because they're evil factories and i'm
not even just talking about firearms i
don't want my child to go to school and
be told by a teacher that they should
affirm whatever gender they feel like
because they happen to be trying to look
up the barbie skirt and they believe
that this my son is now a woman so
that's an aside that's why i say i'm
trying to button it up
well that they have no worth that's a
fun thing to teach kids yes exactly
why are they mentally ill i don't
understand
so we told them they have no meaning or
purpose right
yeah so strange because i don't know
skin color yeah
we've been dividing them by color and
making them hate each other i don't know
what's going on and then also ironically
right ironically telling them that
actual division is racist yeah weird
so no that's that racist long division
yeah yeah yeah i thought it was a
political division here's another thing
so you look at the states in the united
states then you look at other countries
there are plenty of countries in europe
that have bans on firearms that have
bans on specific firearms they still
experience mass casualty events yeah
okay i mean we bring this overlay here
it's just collage i mean just in case
you need your your memory refreshed they
have mass stabbings they have people
being run over with trucks they still
have mass shootings by the way in these
countries yeah so even assuming that
what they're saying is correct and that
criminals would obey the laws it doesn't
work and then of course there's the
very significant underlying factor that
criminals don't well you have the
evidence it's not like we need to do a
case study on this we have places that
we can look that have very tight gun
laws and we can see what happens
california new york being among them but
let's just go to chicago
i don't want to no no
chicago this is real life it's not come
back it's no family matters four people
shot in chicago's a slow weekend dude
leroy brown not even kidding yeah
it's incredible like you can look in
these places that say here's how to fix
the problem let's let's do everything
that we can to fix it from what we know
background all this stuff fine you've
done it didn't work yep next let's go to
something that works right please no
virtue signaling i don't care if you're
going to get down on your hands and
knees and not actually get down on your
hands and knees and act like you care
do something that will solve the problem
yeah
don't give women who are
in danger of being raped a card this
isn't like the joker where it's like
rape is wrong yeah tell them to pee and
vomit on themselves like that nyu or
columbia professor you know really turn
off the uh pcp'd out rapist yeah i don't
really think so not so much he's like
especially if he's in a fraternity yeah
usually they're pretty pretty set in
their ways yeah exactly but hey
unbelievable a little bit put on yeah a
little bit of throw up i don't think is
going to stop a rapist they actually
taught women that and they act like
we're the absurd ones just
yeah yeah vomit and piss on command and
that'll stop the rape okay now that's
appalling like
you note this how oh yeah nick of sir
and nick the polo not to mention how are
you gonna how are you gonna crap and
piss on demand you're just jogging
you're just stocking up on eating bad
pork and iced tea before you go running
in central park
take off your pants thank god for those
amtrak clams
that's why he's one of the best
comedians ever i think the applebee's
chicken palm is coming
are you sure you want to keep doing this
oh my gosh it's one of my favorite
places i can't even imagine that
actually stopping a rapist going well
this is too far what do you think she
was going to have fun yeah she's
probably going to puke anyway if she's
not into it it really ruins the rape for
me yeah i just ugh
[ __ ] i want her to love me
[Laughter]
it's actually probably a better way to
stop the rape just tell them you love
them
i don't know about this commitment this
is a commitment yeah now uh a very good
time can we do this again yeah
ask for cab fare yeah
now uh let's go to another claim that's
gonna take a little bit of time here
this is another claim this is the fifth
claim and this is one that's being
recycled but they try and reframe it
and the idea here is and you can see
this all over twitter that the second
amendment doesn't protect
assault weapons
which by the way is an undefinable term
right it's fluid you know like that
penis between your legs if it looks
scary that's what they pretty much mean
yeah yeah so here's the thing what they
try and often argue and then i want to
get to what the actual second amendment
means but they say oh you know what if
the second amendment if they knew that
people would have these high capacity
guns uh and to go they never would they
would have uh they would have not
allowed with okay first off
on a pragmatic level that's not true
there were plenty of guns that weren't
just muskets there was a gerundo air
rifle there was a pepper box revolver
there was a puckle gun there was the the
belt and flintlock these were things
that existed the reason they just
weren't in large circulations because
they were too expensive
our founding fathers were aware of that
not only were they aware of that
but they were also aware of and gave
their stamp of approval on cannons
artillery was approved artillery was
approved
like a subprime loan what
we want cannons why yes
no trouble
unbelievable so james madison that's
right this is uh overlay and he wrote a
letter of mark uh explaining uh to uh
this is overlay and there uh kevin i
know tocono is not here so overlay and
i'm not going in order they were asking
was a private ship that said you know we
have to deal with uh trouble on the high
seas yeah we just want to know you mean
that's that whole second amendment that
you did yeah does it apply to cannons
and madison was like yeah it applies to
cannons why do you think we wrote it why
not
so what's the equivalent to a cannon
today
it's at least a rocket launcher this is
a very lazy argument they want you to
believe that it was just about muskets
that's not true there were other
firearms and there was artillery and it
was expressly approved by the people who
wrote the second amendment it's a lazy
argument reference is available at
lightworkcrater.com now
they also try and say well the second
amendment here's a problem because they
want to do away with the second
amendment
and so they say well the second
amendment is just for it's just for the
militia
right what probably are you're not in
the militia this is an argument that
they use again it's a really lazy
argument let me read you the second
amendment for people who haven't read it
it's a short read i recommend it
says a well-regulated militia comma
being necessary to the security of a
free state comma
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed so it
doesn't say the right of the militia
to keep in bear arms it says a
well-regulated militia meaning country
needs a militia
then there are two commas between that
and then the right of the people to keep
in birming why is it written that way
it's very clear well let's look to the
the supporting documents george mason
once said i ask sir what is the militia
it is the whole people except for a few
public officials which i love that he
decided to highlight that so the right
what is a militia the militia is you and
that doesn't mean that you have to join
a militia in the woods what it means is
you have a country very very different
from other countries too that's why i
like to compare within states because we
shouldn't compare us to canada no why
because they suck
also
they
bent over
for the royalty they still have the
queen on their money yeah we fought a
bloody war for our freedom some other
historical context just so you know
if george washington was the kind of
shitty politician like like senator
murphy
right who just wanted to i don't know as
steve kerr might say maintain his grip
of power keep in mind george washington
is one of the only few people throughout
history who was one of if not the most
powerful man in the new world in the
whole world but certainly the new world
people were begging for him to stay and
he left and he said because i'm not
immune to power corrupting
that's a big deal not many people do
that he also fought other militias a lot
of people don't realize this you think
there's the war of independence and it
was a civil war no there were wars being
fought here in the united states because
there were some people who i know as
crazy as this may sound wanted to be
loyal to the crown yeah there were some
there were all kinds of factions george
washington had to fight them the easiest
thing he could have done
would have stripped them of the right to
own firearms
oh my gosh i'm running into these
militias who disagree with us but he
understood it was so important that he
still
affirmed it repeatedly repeatedly
because he understood that that is what
was necessary to keep the kind of
government that they just fled in check
and he also recognized that he could be
that kind of a government that he could
be that kind of and at that point really
he government but we didn't have exactly
what we have right now this man was
powerful this man could have been a king
and he recognized ooh that's bad one of
the failsafes here
is the people to have guns there they
need to be their own militia
yeah this is the only way you secure
freedom what is it saying they're being
necessary
to secure
or for for the security of a free state
yep right free security free security
see those things tied together the only
way free stays is if you have security
the only way you get security is if you
have the right to keep and bear arms
yeah it's very very clear look at
countries throughout history we don't
have to go to germany we can go to
australia last year they're building
camps they buy they did mandatory
buybacks of firearms forever right
how do you defend yourself against a
tyrannical government how do you defend
yourself against a tyrannical individual
in your community if you have no right
to keep and bear arms but that person
can go out and get whatever they want
right right they're not going to obey
the laws anyway and if you're like oh if
the entire united states just had the
law fine fantastic how close was this to
the border how many guns are coming over
that border illegally right now you
telling me you couldn't get one if you
really wanted one the argument doesn't
really hold up these are the same people
who require you to get a negative covid
test or quarantine if you're coming back
into your own country for i think it's
ten days but you have hundreds of
thousands of illegal immigrants who just
right on through sir yes right here
please go this way well you're right
in seven years i like your gun yes i
like the cut of that egg i like the
ivory grips and the god-awful gaudy
flames etched into it i like the blood
of the machete yes
you must be what are they called cartel
am i pronouncing that right i don't want
to
vent yes
have you seen our wonderful evt cards we
have a fantastic selection yes please
take one take two yes i know we don't
care we've been playing around with
screen prints look this is uh this ebt
card has dora the explorer are you
familiar probably not but uh you know
what take that that's for you yeah
so let's just
let's let's just tie a bow on this so
second amendment make sure that the
other
the other rights exist yeah scale back
even you know ukraine and russia yeah
scale back that they need guns we're
literally let's just let's put a finer
point on this
your money
billions 40 billion was just the last
round i don't i can't even keep a tally
of the total amount of billions that
have gone to ukraine billions of your
dollars
are right now going
to paying for guns for people in the
ukraine so they can be a well-regulated
militia which you were insured as your
own right at the founding of this
country and they want to strip from you
your money is going to ukraine to pay
for their guns
well they want to take yours
does that drive it home
let's be you don't even need to look
through history you look at it now for
crown and then let's scale it back okay
not ukraine not just china not be people
being run over with tanks not genocide
being committed think a few uyghurs
would like to have a couple of ar-15s
don't want to speak for them but
scale it back speech laws
you can be arrested in australia in
canada in the uk for speech
i'm not saying that all free speech here
is defended with firearms but it's
certainly in the back of people's minds
it's certainly the back of
if you have corrupt police officers
minds who would want to go door-to-door
arresting you for things that you say
which by the way has happened throughout
human history and still happens today
hey remember this this is how this is
the problem with the affront
that the left uh
they just think that they win by being
offended remember yesterday yes that's a
good point remember yesterday when i
said uh uh there are more slaves than
ever in recorded history we have 40
million today yeah and i said now the
problem is the reason we can't talk
about it is because these slaves
primarily exist in you know three places
right africa asia the middle east yeah
so now it's really hard to [ __ ] about
white privilege
when you actually acknowledge the
slavery that is currently currently
taking place in these can i and i said
can i say [ __ ] countries about the
countries that employ slavery and i said
i bet you
liberals are going to be more offended
that i referred to these countries that
enslave people as shitholes than they
will be at
the enslavement guess what media matters
had oh i wonder
steven goes on offensive rant about
[ __ ] countries
yeah you know what hold on a second i
know you're expecting me to apologize i
think if your country still practices
slavery you're a [ __ ] ridiculous
yeah also if you think
if you think one sentence is a rant you
two are a [ __ ] yes
i thought you were saying you too is a
[ __ ] because that is and if you are
the band you too that is uncle could be
true yeah that's true you can have two
shitholes in one [ __ ]
saving time it's a two-first explainer
so these are the these are the myths
that you have out there right can we go
left really quickly oh my god okay
what's going on are you trying to debate
marco rubio no no here's the deal send
senate dems move to clearway for votes
on background checks all right let me
see what they're doing right now all
these mass shootings that have been
purchased at a gun show at the on the
internet so if people want to do that we
can have that debate but don't link it
to these horrible events because they
would have nothing to do with it what
about getting rid of ar-15s why are
these semi-automatic rifles necessary
if people want to talk about banning
specific guns they should propose that
but it wouldn't prevent these shootings
again well let's see what he says here
objective
says he plans to push forward separate
legislation to deal with improving
school safety it's unclear whether or
not that will get democratic support the
democratic senate okay chuck schumer has
promised to move forward on these house
pass bills
background checks on commercial sales
and private transfers he has been saying
that they would move forward on this for
the past year they plan to move
the signaling they plan to move very
quickly on this but even if they were to
do so getting the support of 50 let
alone 60 senators is impossible
democratic congressman colin already all
right let's see what he says let's see
we went through the myths right the
assault weapons the idea of the second
amendment the idea of uh what was the
first one there's the gun lobby yeah we
went through so we went through all the
myths right let's see if he actually
uses in real time let's see if he tries
to perpetuate these he's cleared me on
kate you know as i'm sure you did
you know my wife and i
hugged our two boys a little bit closer
last night everybody did across the
country
i think imagined how they would feel oh
we also have that we're the only country
that does this let's see if you know as
a parent this is your worst nightmare
getting a call
that your precious baby who you sent off
to school has been murdered
and as a texan i'm you know i'm
heartbroken but as a lawmaker i feel
like it's incumbent upon me and my
colleagues to not just grieve but to act
to do something
marco rubio is wrong with what he just
said that there's nothing we can do i
refuse to accept that there's nothing i
can do to protect my kids and their
studies he didn't say that he never said
there's nothing we can do he said those
things wouldn't what you are suggesting
wouldn't have to live like stop the
shooting the only major country
developed country oh ding ding ding hey
that was claim number one that we're the
only country there you go hit a bell
that's for sure i want to read for you
what will references
i've already addressed it we're not is
the former republican 83rd when it comes
to uh
gun crime homicide we're not even the
top country in the new world
in the first world in the non-shithole
world as far as mass shootings that's
false
it's so predictable guys that's the
value in doing this live right a lot of
other conservatives are afraid to go
live this way because they're afraid
they'll get removed from youtube i don't
care you guys go over to rumble go over
to mug club you get to see live in real
time it's the difference between you
know fox news and a lot of am radio it's
kung fu it's oh man i got tiger fist and
i got monkey claw and stuff that i would
do but they never actually get in the
fight in real time that's why we have
cnn right now
let's see what else he hits i guarantee
you if they have i guarantee if we sit
in war cnn for 30 minutes every single
claim that we have just rebutted will
come up but let's just see uh this uh um
b league uh
there is a chance of changing the views
now of elected texas republicans
you know i i want to you know thank will
hurd for that statement i think it takes
bravery for him to put that out
but from what i've seen from our
statewide elected republicans just in
the hours after the shooting yesterday
i don't see a lot of willingness to act
and you know the truth is we have to
have a democratic small d democratic
response to this if folks are not
willing
to get the president in place policies
that will keep our communities safe then
they shouldn't be in positions of
leadership and they shouldn't be you
know creating these laws you know we
have an 18 year old here who could not
buy a beer
who can walk into a gun store and buy
two
assault rifles and hundreds of rounds of
ammunition the shooter in sandy hook was
20 years old you know he had a handgun
why don't you talk about the handgun
also by the way brought them through a
background check talk about that all of
these examples that we're talking about
this guy
wasn't in his mom's safe yeah i think it
was his parents yeah but it wouldn't
stop every single one but if we can save
any lives
if it would save any lives
1.6 million last year
an average of two and a half million
defensive uses of firearms we don't know
if those all say every single time a
life is safe let's call it a million
to 14 or 16 000 gun homicides the vast
majority of which are gang on gang
violence if it saves one life how about
1.6 million how about securing the
schools because that's something hey i'm
just talking about the numbers how about
1.6 million lives you piece of [ __ ]
i just love how they played as they're
trying to protect the guns and not the
kids no we're trying to protect the kids
with guns yeah because that's how you do
it let's see what other myths you can do
you can't pretend that they don't exist
right you can't pretend that evil
doesn't exist but then again these are
the people who are perpetuating evil
like chop chopping off a six-year-old's
penis let's see what else he says on you
know for example veterans issues here
you know in my area who i'm you know
thinking of right now
who may be you know candidates to talk
to about you know where can we begin
to break this ice now of course you know
the house has passed legislation and you
know i'm a member of the house
and so what we're talking about
ultimately is also what can get through
the senate and what can get 60 votes in
the senate but maybe uh if we can get
enough support for action in the house
that would pressure you know 10
republican senators to join uh us in
doing the right thing but you know what
was said earlier i think an earlier
segment about how our inability to act
on this is a reflection of how broken
our politics is is absolutely true you
know if we can't protect that's
predicated on the idea that your action
doesn't suck
is there ever any accountability the
fact that republicans and by the way a
good portion of democrats don't want to
support our bills which would do nothing
is proof that you shouldn't trust your
institutions and then we'll blame you
for not trusting your institutions
our politics are broken um specifically
ours yes
uh because we were totally legally
brought in now let me tell you about how
we need background checks as i tell you
about how this man bought two firearms
while going through a background check
james what's the proposed legislative
which proposed legislation more
background checks i'm being told by the
cnn producer i should not have shot this
in my toxic masculinity room with a
football helmet yes
i'm also being told that i am not
allowed to do my live read for aqua
velva hmm
[Music]
democrats in congress we've been trying
to act for two years it's those senate
republicans up there that don't want
your kids protected and marco rubio has
just a moment where he says well yeah
these things aren't linked together what
i think we should do is maybe start
securing our schools i'm going to put
forward legislation well but what about
those ar 15s you totally skipped off
yeah totally it's got a solution no no
it's worse than that there it's worse
than that he said what about why does
anyone need an ar-15 those
semi-automatic rifles oh and now you
shoot worn in semi-automatic guess what
semi-automatic guess what all handguns
semi-automatic revolver's effectively
semi-automatic though they're not by
mechanism but really it's pull
semi-automatic one trigger pull and i
have to say that because unfor hey look
gun guys and gun chicks you could also
shut up okay because say well revolver
is technically not a semi-automatic i
know but when we're talking about it
means one trigger pull one shot fully
automatic machine gun the problem is
then you have gun people who come in who
then wants to let everyone know what
they don't know about firearms we
shouldn't be arguing about that [ __ ]
i understand what a semi-automatic is
versus a revolver i'm saying for all
intents and purposes when describing it
to people people need to know what would
be on the chopping block they're trying
to make it seem like an ar-15 is a
gatling gun on top of a on top of a
horse carriage
this is all firearms outside of pump and
lever actions
pump shotguns lever actions maybe bolt
actions any gun that you have that is
one trigger pull
and that
fires around a bullet leaves that barrel
that's a semi-automatic so he sure owns
that in there what about hr what about
background checks and then also ar15s
because semi-automatic and now you've
managed to be effective in associating
in the american people's mind that wait
ar-15 is crazy and it's semi-automatic
and so okay yeah i guess i would support
banning semi-automatics it's just those
ar15s when it's really every single
handgun that exists in your house
unbelievable it's it's totally
believable this is exactly what they do
every single time i know it's what they
do every single time but their policies
why don't you at least say okay let's
secure the schools as well like i get
that you have a really you got a big
hard-on for background checks i
understand that fine
why don't you say okay let's do both
let's do every single possible thing
that we can it's because you want power
it's because you want to be right and
you want the republicans to be wrong
well guess what their solution works
yours doesn't we're just going to live
in this hell until you realize that or
we vote your ass out of office which
hopefully will happen soon this year
yeah you don't go into bullet frequency
it's insane
it's a bullet in a gun it doesn't it it
can be used
as evil it's it's all it comes down to
well it doesn't i mean take that
argument out of it well they don't want
to take it out of it if you're in a room
of sitting ducks of children it doesn't
matter you have the control right the
only way the control can be taken away
which was proven again yesterday is by
protecting the children yeah why we're
just letting our kids like if you want
to talk about the all lives matter stuff
it does matter with children that's it
yeah because they're the ones that
actually have a chance in this life
right
and we we've taken that away well you're
so tired of this [ __ ]
sorry it's just it's you have a chance
too i mean they're not the only ones who
have a chance we all have a chance we
all have a chance but i mean kids i just
think should be the most protected part
of our society and we're going hey let's
let's give that young man fake tits and
don't make sure he's not protected yes
wait do you mean do you mean sexually or
the fire in both whatever we just don't
want to judge yeah you just mentioned
something and i and you know what i want
to uh
leave on this and then we actually have
to go to hey by the way did they get did
the control room get us is it 21 for a
handgun in texas
did they do their job and get that to us
still looking now yeah but guys is it 21
or is it 18 in texas that should be it
used to be 21 when we shot that video i
didn't know if they changed i know
rifles are 18. uh that's like a 30
30 second quick search if you guys can
grab it i'm pretty sure gerald is right
yeah i think it is too yeah it's still
21 for a handgun but you just talked
about uh holding onto power
and this is what steve kerr said about
republicans
right he said oh you want to hold on let
me ask you something let me ask you
something let's just think about let's
let's pull back a little bit okay
power for politicians all right power
for people who are in office power for
anyone who's in a position of authority
or power right the monarchy
whether it's parliament
take your pick okay they're in power now
it's not just some kind of we're not
just talking about genocide if we're not
talking about power through force right
you're talking about something that's
some kind of a
democracy or socialist but whatever you
wanna okay what is required for them to
be in power especially a country this
size for you to what be dependent on
them
for them to be powerful they need you to
be dependent on them they need you to
what
it's just like a relationship an abusive
relationship where they need you to be
codependent
if you are self-sufficient someone has
less power you know this in your life
right hey ever paid off your debt
does that person have less power over
you you're no longer dependent on them
ever leave your parents house
your parents
hold less power over you of course
because you're now a self-sufficient man
or woman now when we understand that
basic principle and they try and accuse
the republicans or the right or people
like me of wanting to
assert power i don't know how i would do
that this is all voluntary this
interaction and transaction here sorry
no transaction unless you join my club
we don't make a dime on youtube
um
be fear right that's what would be most
important here would be fear if i need
you to be dependent okay let's let's
let's create a scenario republicans all
right hey
we want to close the border from illegal
immigrants and also of course for guns
that are being run through drug cartels
we want you to be able to own firearms
and we want people to be able to carry
these firearms and gun-free zones
and that we shouldn't be able to take
that from you also we want to lower your
taxes and give you more freedom as it
relates to your choices we're going to
give you less free stuff
but we want to secure the border
we want you to have guns
oh and by the way we also believe in at
least deporting the illegal immigrants
here who are in our prisons
now how much power does that person hold
over you if that's the world you live in
this country you have a secure border
you have a firearm
versus
an open border which we know they try to
end title 42 we have more border
crossings more illegal immigrants
flooding in than ever before
and we want to take away your guns and
by the way we want to raise your taxes
but we'll give you free insert whatever
it is here
internet health care
what else with student loans
what happens if the government forgives
your loan let me ask you this just use
the example of the debt of a debtor okay
if you owe the bank money
and
we forgive your student loan
and by way i mean the taxpayer and so
the government has now raised taxes
but has decided you no longer owe the
bank to whom are you indebted
you're now just indebted to the
government
do you understand that every single
policy that comes from the left is about
enslaving you
economically
or i mean really almost at this point i
would almost say because it's a religion
bordering on theologically certainly
they want you to be indoctrinated
they don't want you to
simply be allowed to express other
opinions and where could i base that
australia canada uk france speech laws
so just let's just look at these two
separate worlds
who's trying to get a stranglehold on
power the people who say we want to
secure the border we want you to have
guns who want to lower taxes and give
you more choices and i know they don't
do that in practice or the people who
say
no guns open borders higher taxes and
you owe it to us for crying out loud
they want to be like an abusive pimp and
you know what pimps generally don't want
their prostitutes to have guns on them
because that's pimp's only business
we're going to go to a mug club here in
a second which is the only way that we
keep the lights on please do consider
joining livecar.com we also have
wonderful sponsors you know when i
actually did that
uh range uh i had walking pneumonia
bronchial infection sinus infection and
uh i think that was when i started using
this the x clear nasal spray started
clearing things out every time i go to a
gun range i use it because i get like
gun powder you know
you ever go to the range and your nails
oh yeah right you have to wash your
hands and you think about washing your
hands but you're also wash your nose
right clear it's a nasal spray with
xylitol in there it's doctor recommended
you can get it over the counter or at
amazon go to clearxclear.com and by the
way there are published clinical
studies and trials as it relates to
allergies covid
and all kinds of other respiratory
illnesses because you just think about
you wash your face you wash your hands
you wash your balls but you don't even
you you have an idea what you're
breathing in every day yeah your idea
what i'm breathing in with these animals
here in this studio
i scrub my balls
unfortunately you do it in the uh on the
golf course and any drinking fountain i
can find that's public well you know
what depends on the height yeah it's all
about the dip effect
what am i doing barbershop quartet ball
washing yeah wash those balls now steve
oh
i call them baldes yes
all right we're going to actually check
because we do think and we love them we
want to be in a safe place we think
gingersnap here uh in the studio uh
might be gay we're going to get to the
bottom of it on mod club light of
course.com club liberals you will not
get any firearms from the studio and uh
within reach
there are many guns piss off
you